so you're a mexican drug cartel and
you're looking to make more money you're
definitely not above using drugs and
human trafficking to make a profit and
you're also not above using theft
violence kidnapping to get what you want
but like any cartel you also want to
diversify your income streams if all
your money comes from illegal businesses
those could get shut down seized but if
you use some of your money to open up
some legitimate businesses you could get
some sweet safe cash flow that will act
like a safety net that is where the food
industry comes in
specifically you want to look for fruits
or vegetables that are sold in the u.s
for high prices but mainly come from
mexico something you can monopolize on
your home turf so that you can make bank
without all the danger and inconvenience
of drug trafficking think about it
everyone needs food it's something that
would never go out of demand
enter avocados avocados are one of
america's favorite superfoods i mean i
dare you to find any self-respecting
restaurant that doesn't include avocados
in their menu somehow i am always amazed
at how many different uses you can have
for an avocado avocado toast avocado
cooking oil heck even avocado ice cream
is considered a delicacy and best of all
almost all of america's avocados are
grown right at home in mexico avocados
are such a trendy food item that they
are now a multi-billion dollar industry
for mexican farmers and it only gets
more profitable every year they're even
referred to as green gold but if you're
gonna take over this industry in a
hostile manner you gotta be smart about
it and in this video we're gonna show
you exactly how
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player
your parents teachers friends society
will never teach you any of this so
we're going to you've heard of blood
diamonds you may have heard of the
conflict minerals used for electric cars
like cobalt now it's time to learn about
blood avocados
[Music]
do you like free stuff well you can get
up to 12 free stocks yes up to 12 free
stocks value up to 30 600 when you sign
up for weeble with the link below and
deposit any amounts yes you can
literally deposit as little as one
dollar after opening an account and
you'll still get the free stocks so you
might as well pause the video and click
the link below to claim it now and
signing up to get your free stocks is
super fast and easy all you have to do
is fill out some basic information to
open an account on weibull deposit any
amount you want into your account and
then boom you'll get up to 12 free
stocks
the first two shares you get when you
open your account would be valued up to
300 each and the next 4 to 10 shares you
get when you deposit any amount into
your account would be valued up to 3 000
each and yes once the stocks have
settled in your accounts you can sell
them use that money to buy other stocks
or even withdraw the money the only
catch is that this promotion is not
going to last forever so you're going to
want to do this as soon as possible if
you're not aware weeble is a really
great commission free stock trading app
that was ranked the best investment app
in 2021 by benzinga and it has a 4.5
star rating from nerd wallet
true wealth is made when there's blood
in the streets and with the recession
just arriving it's more important than
ever to make sure you have everything
set up so that you can buy when there's
fear in the stock market so what are you
waiting for get your 12 free stocks
value up to 30 600 right now by pausing
the video and clicking the link below
thanks to weeble for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
when most people think of organized
crime they think of drugs human
trafficking political corruption and the
like they don't usually think of mundane
things like food
but the fact of the matter is avocado
imports are worth far more than
marijuana imports these days which is
pretty insane if you think about it and
it makes avocados a big deal for a
cartel's bottom line the fruit is now
called green gold for a reason and there
are a few different routes you can take
to make money off of this green gold
one
steal truckloads of it
right now cartels are already making off
with over four truckloads of avocados a
day
this translates to thousands upon
thousands of stolen fruit every year
that the cartels can then turn around
and sell to food companies at no cost to
themselves
just take this example where three
california men were arrested for selling
three hundred thousand dollars worth of
stolen avocados three hundred thousand
dollars
from just three people and they aren't
even part of an elaborate organized
crime syndicate just imagine how much
you can make with this route
two offer some protection
ah yes the good old protection racket
this one is simple if you're not
familiar you simply create the problem
and then offer the solution you hire
some muscle to intimidate avocado
farmers or even rough up a bit to get
their message across
and then you come to them as their
savior and say hey for the small price
of tens of thousands of dollars we'll
make sure those thugs never mess with
you again
if they don't accept your generous offer
well you just send more thugs their way
until they submit
three
take over farms completely go onto an
avocado farm and simply take it over
these small-time farmers can't defend
themselves from a mighty cartel army
it's not uncommon for a farmer with
large amounts of land and established
avocado trees to wake up one morning and
find half of what he owns has been
claimed by cartel members
which works out great for the cartels
because all of the hard work of
developing the land and growing the
trees has already been done for them
they can just get right to harvesting
they can even come in and optimize the
business by replacing those expensive
adult workers with child labor
four do the same thing to avocado
packaging plants packaging plants are a
major bottleneck in the avocado industry
control the packaging plants and you can
charge honest farmers very high
extortion fees to use them and since
they need the packaging plants to sell
and ship their crop there isn't anything
they can do to stop you taking over
packaging plants also gives you another
key benefit it allows you to launder
your bloody avocados
see money laundering is usually when you
have to mix money you got from illegal
means with money you got from legitimate
means like a restaurant or something but
what do you do when it's not illegal
money you have to clean but illegal
avocados
simple you take over an avocado
packaging plant so that you can mix in
your blood avocados with clean
legitimate ones from real farmers
that way your blood avocados can never
be traced back to organized crime
because of this cartels frequently
attack packaging plants and complete
takeovers are extremely common
5. kidnap and murder family members of
farmers
remember you're a cartel you're already
an expert in using kidnappings and
murders as a way to get what you want
why not bring that high income skill
over into this arena
fear will always be a powerful tool that
can be used to make large profits with
minimal effort whether it's to enforce
their protection fees kidnap some free
labor or just as a scare tactic to
intimidate and control farmers it's no
longer a surprise for farmers family
members to just disappear at the hands
of the cartels
but because of all this avocado farmers
have gotten a little creative to combat
cartels
at first the farmers of michoacan turned
to local governments for help and asked
them to activate the national guard
those local governments said they would
help but ended up not doing anything
as a result farmers have had to take
matters into their own hands so they
formed their own avocado militias first
they bought their own guns most of these
are unregistered guns and while that's
illegal in mexico desperate times call
for desperate measures and although none
of them have ever fired a gun before in
their lives they had no choice but to
learn
they call themselves pueblos unidos or
united towns and together the group
works to defend their farms and the town
they live in
it's extremely dangerous to do this but
wherever pueblos unidos has to set up
shop the thefts and kidnappings have at
least slowed down
they've even had to go so far as to set
up road blockades across most of the
state of michoacan and will stop passing
cars to inspect for weapons other groups
of farmers and packaging plants have
pooled together to pay for protection
from private security companies they may
be losing the same amount of money but
they would rather pay a security company
to pay the cartels the result of all of
this is that things are getting tense on
both sides of the aisle but with that
amount of green gold at stake who can
blame them
we're gonna kick
your i'm sorry what are you doing adding
avocados from mexico
avocados have become the next conflict
commodity we've seen it happen before
with blood diamonds cobalt and oil and
as alarming as it may sound to compare
avocados with blood diamonds this is
definitely not the first time a food
product has seen blood
cocoa production was exploited in cote
d'ivoire for years it was used to raise
millions of us dollars on both sides of
the conflict
between the national government and the
armed rebel group named the forces
nouvelles
the only true difference between this
situation and the mexican avocado
industry is that the exploitation is not
perpetrated by government and rebels but
by organized crime both have
assassinations modern slavery child
labor and much more
what we shouldn't do to stop organized
crime and avocados is shut down avocado
commerce completely because shutting
down the avocado business would probably
do more to hurt honest farmers than it
would the cartels
and mexican farmers already experienced
some of that pain in february this year
a usda worker doing inspections in a
michoacan packaging plant was verbally
threatened by certain unsavory elements
this resulted in a ban on avocado
imports on february 11th
the ban only lasted about 10 days before
it was lifted due to this the price of
avocados skyrocketed in a severe supply
shortage that just happened to be right
before avocado's biggest event of the
year
the super bowl
americans eat an average of 280 million
avocados during super bowl weekend and
with their cash crop crumbling under a
severe shortage after only a week there
was no way the ban could continue
the company avocados from mexico
actually released a super bowl themed
commercial for their cash crop product
just three days before the ban occurred
even though the ban was lifted for more
cynical reasons like the public
demanding their guacamole back the fact
remains
one in five residents of michoacan
worked directly in the avocado industry
without the avocado trade not only would
americans lose access to one of their
favorite super foods but mexican farmers
would lose their livelihoods
[Music]
the cartel takeover of the avocado
industry is pretty messed up people need
food to live which makes doing dirty
business with food especially messed up
and that's what makes one company in
particular arguably just as evil in its
own way compared to the cartels and that
company is monsanto one of the most evil
corporations out there and the company
that owns the entire world's food supply
and that is only the tip of the monsanto
iceberg
monsanto was the same company that
created agent orange the poison that was
sprayed all over vietnam during the
vietnam war that devastated the
population and a lot of more super
messed up stuff and we've compiled all
of it into a single feature-length
documentary exposing every dirty detail
but the thing is the video is a little
too spicy to post publicly because
talking about the graphic effects of all
the chemicals they used will probably
get demonetized that's why we decided to
release it as a private documentary
available only to members of this
channel and so far it's a hit
all you have to do to watch the monsanto
documentary right now and all the other
docs that are just too controversial for
the public is to hit the join button
below after you sign up you'll get full
access to the monsanto documentary plus
others like our latest one on the
connection between victoria's secret and
everyone's favorite private island owner
every jepsty
these exclusive documentaries hold some
of the darkest craziest secrets about
how the world works it's the type of
stuff they should be teaching you in
university but aren't and unlike
university we're not gonna charge you
tens of thousands of dollars because you
get all this for just five dollars a
month and there's a refund policy too
unlike most youtube memberships so if
you join and you don't think it's worth
it email us within your first month of
joining and we will personally refund
you for your first month after your
first month there is no refund so scroll
down and hit that join button below now
are you gonna eat avocado still because
i definitely will hope you guys enjoyed
the video and if you're new here this is
one of the biggest channels on youtube
for documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this one we make
multiple videos just like this one every
single week for free so click that
subscribe button below don't forget to
get your 12 free stocks on weeble with
the link below you can follow me on
instagram at jtran but that's going to
wrap it up thanks for being part of the
watch the end club state angels out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you